Trascrizione: Sarah Lupi
Quando mi chiedono che lavoro faccio
ho sempre un po' di difficoltà,
non so mai bene cosa rispondere.
Il motivo è che
non faccio una cosa sola ma,
ne faccio molte, forse.
Il motivo è che il mio lavoro abbraccia
tante discipline.
Include la matematica, la medicina,
la biologia, la statistica, la fisica,
l'informatica.
E poi anche perché il lavoro che faccio
cerca di rispondere a delle domande
che non sono proprio domande facili.
E allora, quando mi fanno questa domanda,
la prendo alla larga.
Magari siamo a cena, inizio a dire:
"Mi occupo di capire cosa
c'è nelle cellule umane,
mi occupo di capire cos'è
che distingue cellula da cellula,
cos'è il genoma,
e di fatto quello che davvero
dovrei dire è che studio il genoma
delle cellule tumorali.
E spesso
mi sono sentita un po' come Ted,
come un pesce in una boccia così,
o magari spesso
anche come un pesce fuor d'acqua.
In realtà quello che faccio
ve lo spiego con una scena astratta.
Immaginate un paziente che ha saputo
di avere un tumore e che si reca
dal proprio medico.
Gli vengono fatti degli esami,
dei test di vario tipo
e poi dopo qualche settimana,
o magari anche qualche giorno,
gli viene prescritto un trattamento
che uccide tutte le sue cellule tumorali.
E così il tumore sparisce.
Sembra un pensiero così semplice
ma anche così,
forse di magia, sembra quasi un'utopia.
Eppure questo è quello che noi
cerchiamo di fare,
questo è quello che noi chiamiamo
la "medicina di precisione",
cioè quella disciplina
che cerca di identificare il farmaco
per un paziente
sulla base del DNA
che c'è nelle sue cellule tumorali,
il DNA dell'individuo,
e che viene dato nel momento giusto
e nella dose giusta.
Questa è la medicina di precisione,
quella per la quale noi
lavoriamo.
Ora, a scuola
ci hanno insegnato che il DNA
è il depositario
delle nostre caratteristiche.
Nel nostro DNA c'è scritto
se siamo castani, biondi, rossi
se siamo alti,
se siamo un po' bassi, tipo me,
se da adulti possiamo digerire il latte,
se siamo in grado
di tollerare bene la birra.
Ci sono un sacco di cose
scritte nel nostro DNA.
In ciascuna delle 37 milioni di milioni
di cellule che compongono il nostro corpo
c'è una copia di DNA.
E se noi srotoliamo il DNA, che è sempre
molto compatto, è lungo 1 metro,
un metro tipo così:
un passo, un mio passo.
Questo è il mio DNA.
E se poi lo confronto
con il vostro DNA
è quasi tutto identico
tranne in un centimetro:
una piccola, piccola percentuale.
E la cosa bella è che questo centimetro,
che, di fatto, è fatto
di tante unità sparse,
ci rende tutti diversi
uno dall'altro, ci rende unici.
Il DNA, di fatto,
è anche molto organizzato,
non solo nella struttura
ma anche nella sua linearità.
Sono 3 miliardi,
più di 3 miliardi di lettere,
perfettamente ordinate
e noi possiamo pensarlo come un libro,
con tantissime parole, ovviamente,
tante pagine.
E tutto questo è vero
per tutte le nostre 37 milioni
di milioni di cellule sane,
ed è anche vero, di fatto,
per le cellule tumorali.
Solo che nelle cellule tumorali
ci sono degli errori,
degli errori tipografici.
Per esempio, una lettera sparisce,
una lettera viene ribaltata,
una parola intera sparisce,
oppure magari un'intera frase,
invece che essere stampata una sola volta,
nelle nostre cellule malate,
nelle cellule tumorali,
è stampata
5, 7, 10 volte.
E questo
è quello che noi dobbiamo capire,
noi ricercatori dobbiamo trovare
tutti questi
"errori tipografici",
che chiamiamo "mutazioni"
e dobbiamo identificare quali sono
quelle fondamentali.
Cioè quali sono
questi errori
che rendono la cellula tumorale
in grado di prendere il sopravvento
sulle cellule che ci sono intorno.
E poi magari,
se riusciamo a fare ancora di più
è meglio.
Per esempio,
se riusciamo a capire da quanto
queste cellule tumorali sono nel corpo,
da dove vengono, dove vanno,
che intenzioni hanno.
Se riusciamo a capire queste cose,
abbiamo delle chance in più
per combatterle.
E quindi,
in una frase, quello che dobbiamo fare
è trasformare i loro punti di forza
nel loro tallone d'Achille.
Questo è il nostro lavoro.
Ora, di fatto, io personalmente
sono arrivata a quasi 30 anni senza sapere
molto sul DNA,
non molto di più di quello
che sapete tutti voi.
Ho studiato fisica,
all'Università di Trento
e fisica è quella disciplina bellissima
che studia i fenomeni naturali
e li descrive,
o li spiega, con delle equazioni.
E quindi ho macinato equazioni,
numeri, conti,
per anni.
E,
e poi ancora ho studiato altri algoritmi,
mentre ho fatto il dottorato
in informatica,
altri modi per analizzare i dati,
per capire, per predire.
E a un certo punto
mi sono trovata
ad aver l'occasione
di andare a lavorare
alla scuola di medicina
di Harvard, che si trova a Boston.
E lì ero,
unica fisica,
in un intero dipartimento
di patologia molecolare.
E mi ricordo esattamente il giorno
in cui un ricercatore, molto bravo,
si è seduto
di fronte a me
e mi ha spiegato,
guardandomi dritta negli occhi,
che cos'era una mutazione.
Io son stata attenta ovviamente,
ho cercato di capire
e poi dopo un po'
ho iniziato a capire
che forse quello che avevo imparato,
le equazioni, i conti, i numeri,
potevano essere utili.
Poi ho iniziato a guardarmi intorno,
e ho capito che lì
c'erano tante altre persone come me,
tante persone che venivano
da discipline diverse.
C'era molta contaminazione di discipline.
E la cosa bella
è che tutti cercavamo di rispondere
alle stesse domande.
E poi queste persone erano molto
combattive, molto determinate.
E ho iniziato a sentirmi
non più un pesce fuor d'acqua.
E
e poi sono andata a Cornell,
a New York, all'università,
e lì per la prima volta ho condotto
un gruppo di ricerca
ed ero proprio al crocevia
tra la medicina, l'informatica
e la biologia.
E il mio bagaglio di equazioni
ha iniziato a essere
davvero utile.
Poi, in questi anni
--erano i primi anni 2000--
è successa una cosa molto importante
per la scienza:
ha preso piede
una rivoluzione tecnologica "galattica",
mi viene da dire.
Quella che
ci ha portato a utilizzare
le tecniche del sequenziamento
nella nostra routine.
E qui vediamo un video.
Era come--
All'inizio era come poter guardare
dall'alto vie e case,
poi, grazie al sequenziamento,
abbiamo potuto entrare
--ehm--
quasi
nelle dispense,
contare tutti i chicchi di riso
che ci sono
in un contenitore, in una dispensa,
in una cucina
e non solo contarli, ma anche guardare
se sono simili tra loro,
guardare se qualcuno
ha qualche striatura un po' diversa,
come in questa immagine.
Questa è la rivoluzione
che il sequenziamento ha portato.
Ciò consente,
ci ha consentito
di guardare la più piccola unità
del DNA in tutta la sua precisione.
Enorme, enorme trasformazione.
Perché, ovviamente,
se noi applichiamo questa tecnica
alle cellule tumorali
possiamo imparare un sacco di cose.
E così, praticamente, in questo percorso
un po' eterogeneo
dove ero davvero tra persone
molto diverse tra di loro,
ho capito che la mia fortuna
era stata avere le mie equazioni,
essere arrivata nel posto giusto,
con le persone giuste, nel momento giusto
e con la tecnologia
che davvero giocava a nostro favore.
Bene, con tutti questi mezzi in mano,
possiamo iniziare a rispondere
ad alcune delle domande
che ho accennato prima.
È un po' come--
Il nostro lavoro è come trasformare
la realtà, l'esperienza,
o queste montagne bellissime che vediamo,
in una cartina.
La cartina di fatto è la codifica
di tutto quello che c'è nelle montagne.
Ci sono le altitudini,
ci sono i nomi,
ci sono le curve di livello
che danno un sacco di informazione.
È la sintesi di quello che vediamo.
E così, similmente,
con i nostri algoritmi,
se noi prendiamo il DNA
e lo guardiamo
così come fosse un cerchio,
possiamo iniziare a confrontare
nel minimo dettaglio le cellule tumorali
con le cellule sane.
E qui a destra c'è
quello che possiamo vedere
come l'identikit di un paziente.
E ogni piccolo tratto di penna
che c'è in questo identikit
di fatto riassume una montagna,
o più montagne, di dati.
È strepitoso.
Tutto questo
perché c'è il sequenziamento
e possiamo andare a fondo,
a fondo, a fondo.
Poi possiam fare di più:
possiamo confrontarli
e possiamo studiare la dinamica.
Possiamo
capire da dove queste cellule
sono arrivate
e soprattutto dove vogliono andare,
e come si trasformano.
All'inizio di quest'anno abbiamo finito
una ricerca con molti collaboratori
di continenti diversi
dove, per la prima volta, siamo riusciti
a vedere
come una cellula,
come quella di sinistra,
sotto la pressione di un farmaco,
che inizialmente aiutava il paziente,
la cellula si trasforma
per non essere più
prigioniera del farmaco.
Vedete come cambiano.
È cambiata la forma,
son diventate più piccole, più compatte,
sono più dense, sono un po' frastagliate.
È come fosse un contorsionista
che, per sfuggire,
si camuffa
e magari si mette anche un cappotto,
un maglione, una sciarpa o qualcosa
e tu non le riconosci più.
E queste cellule sono in grado
di sfuggire al trattamento.
E la bellezza di questa ricerca,
oltre ad aver imparato qualcosa di nuovo
dal punto di vista della biologia,
è che
possiamo capire quando le cellule
si trasformano,
e aiutare i clinici
a decidere di cambiare trattamento:
questa è la vera bellezza
di queste ricerche.
Ora,
oltre al bello di fare qualcosa
che può essere utile,
il bello
del nostro lavoro
è che è un lavoro creativo.
Perché non ci sono
linee guida,
non ci sono ricette,
e sostanzialmente noi prendiamo
moli di dati enormi,
terabyte di dati,
grandi, grandi, grandi,
in formato magari come questo,
con tanti 0 e 1
e quello che dobbiamo fare è trasformare
quest'informazione in qualcosa di utile,
dobbiamo trasformare
quest'informazione in connessioni.
Un po' come si faceva una volta
con i centralini telefonici,
dove bisognava sapere
dove si voleva andare.
È un po' come cucinare,
e fare una torta senza avere la ricetta.
Magari si ha la ricetta
e non si hanno gli ingredienti, non tutti.
Magari c'è scritto "quanto basta"
e non si sanno le dosi.
È un po' così il nostro lavoro,
bisogna essere fantasiosi, creativi,
bisogna fidarsi dei collaboratori,
bisogna davvero metterci
energia e fantasia.
Davvero fantasia.
È un po' come essere
in prove di volo costanti.
Ogni giorno, ogni settimana, ogni mese.
E,
e ora siamo in una prova di volo
molto grande, siamo in una prova di volo
che durerà per i prossimi 5 anni
perché abbiamo avuto un'idea,
l'anno scorso,
che la Comunità Europea
ha deciso di finanziarci,
ed è un'idea che sfrutta
il tallone di Achille delle cellule
in questo modo,
che vi spiego brevemente.
Ci sono
ci sono delle coppie di mutazioni
che sono completamente nocive
per le cellule tumorali.
Quando accadono contemporaneamente,
la cellula non riesce a tollerarle
e la cellula tumorale,
che è l'unica con le mutazioni, muore.
Allora noi abbiam pensato:
usiamo un po' degli algoritmi
che abbiamo imparato in questi anni
e cerchiamo coppie
con questa proprietà, coppie di mutazioni
che non sono ancora note.
Le cerchiamo guardando a tappeto
su tutto quello che è stato sequenziato
fino adesso,
ovviamente di pazienti,
e poi,
ogni volta che c'è un paziente nuovo
come una delle due mutazioni,
diamo il farmaco contro l'altra,
la creiamo,
e tutte, e solo le cellule tumorali,
così dovrebbero scomparire.
Facile come idea,
forse,
facile anche metterla in pratica.
E noi pensiamo che questa idea,
che abbiamo chiamato "spice"
come le spezie
che si mettono nelle ricette
quando si vuole dare un po' di sapore,
possa essere una strada
per contribuire
alla medicina di precisione.
Sappiamo, siamo molto consci,
ed è importante ricordarlo,
che si tratta di ricerca ancora,
siamo lontani
dal poter applicare queste cose
nella quotidianità della clinica.
Però la strada è tracciata,
siamo sulla giusta via,
sulla giusta rotta.
E quindi noi ci crediamo
e continuiamo in questo modo.
E in questi anni ho imparato
che non sono più un pesce fuor d'acqua
e sono parte di un grande acquario
e mi sento estremamente fortunata
a fare il lavoro che faccio.
Grazie.